始め今日も頑張ろう束ねーババアたありがとう今寝ちゃうはずミス像です今僕の口は
マーシーが効いてます刀鈍松井ってなんなんだかよくわかんないんですけどとりあえず
今こっちのこっちの感覚が全くないん
全然なんて思いたくないもうやばいやばいよしてええほんと困ってるんですよねこの
実話なんですけど去年歯医者に通ってて虫歯があってもう撮っちゃいからちょっと
忙しくなっちゃって愛車に通えなくなってしまいました
で今日久しぶりにちょっと時間があったと言ってきたんですけども
悪化してましたそりゃそうですよそれはそうですよ虫歯1本だったら虫歯二本になって
て松井
な2発ぐらい打たれてじゃあ治療して期末れちゃって来付で取れるんですけど痛いん
ですよ
まあしていた方左てあげてくださいと言われたでも復縁した出荷せて言ってあげて足
もう1本凝ったんん
日本語学者ブレにもう1本松湯桶か言われて
強力な中麻酔を打たれて今に至ります凄いんですよ
麻酔っていうの例えば庫に牛乳があるとしましょうこの牛乳すらオムこちらもずっと
ままならないレベルだと思う
いただきます
[音楽]
いえーい
ねうんん
なんかもう本当にこっちらの力が入らなくてうーん
ani
だけどもう服立論もできないだ母
ほっぺた膨らまことができないんですよこっちが何か力入んないから開いちゃうんです
くらあの今我慢するんですけど今も見たいんですよ
例えばこれます何と弔意という今まだ松井の力で何とかごまかせるわけなんですけどた
もう月するとすごい痛みがくるんで
お菓子にます本当にマジで歯医者行ったほうがいいですよ僕マジで廃車か八かと思って
ますもん
今6個目後半とか食べれるから1人ほどの配布もダメージがあるかわかんないんです
実際に食べてみます
[音楽]
こっちが被って噛めない大丈夫
ふーん
待って多分本当に2位強力な麻酔がかかってるんでうまく噛めない
こちらはねぼく多い中クッキングパパん気になっちゃうね入ってマット困った
練ったり人はそんななんか1暴投みたいな痛さですねどくれてるって本拠普通に歯医者
行って3時にスタートスって終わったらごちたから3時間で時間以上の治療しました
まあ待て
真っすぐが切れてきたバス夕霧だぞああ
taa
920 d のかなというかだめだと気がするのいう薬があーだめだ
抗生物質なもんだってこの性物質こと牛乳ともじゃダメみたいだけですちょっとバイ
バーイパンって待ってホントにマジで痛い歯茎が8位ドクロ30分1個でいいのかにょ
ぷ一条
ロキソニンだよくあるやつはこれ俺は12
二3色を嘲るバンクはないといけません2切れ
楠4位
痛いねほんとにちょっと派がおかしいと思ったらすぐ歯医者に行ってください死ぬほど
痛い思いをしてしまいますしばらく会社通いますでは
me
あっはぁ
この後
二くん